вбивство голодом мільйонів українців
було лише частиною геноцидного плану
Росії іншими складовими були витерти цей
злочин з пам'яті українців і зробити так
щоб світ ніколи не дізнався про нього
пам'ять про Голодомор робить нас
сильними дитячі руки які 20 років тому
стискали свічку пам'яті сьогодні
стискають автомат щоб Ніколи знову Росія
розуміє ця пам'ять робить нас українцями
тому докладала і докладає максимум
зусиль для того щоб спинити поширення
правди про Голодомор в Україні Тут вона
зазнала цілковитої поразки нинішні
злочини Росії допомагає зрозуміти її
злочинні дії у минулому і навпаки
злочини минулого показують коріння
нинішньої геноцидної політики
російського імперіалізму Росія нині
вбиває нас ракетами і кулями тому що
знову не може застосувати голод як зброю
проти нас Ми переможемо Тому що
пам'ятаємо про Голодомор пам'ятаємо ми
сильні Слава Україні